hey what's up my name is samuel lees i'm
so excited right now it's january time
and there's so many people making
serious money in property investment
right now if you know what to do
if you understand that with struggles
comes strength
crisis brings opportunity there's so
much opportunity right now in property
so what i decided to do
was open up a q a session and answer
your
property investment questions right now
on the spot so do me a massive favor
comment your questions below i'm going
to be answering your property
investments
real real soon your questions but right
now we've got a question from
florian van der veen
great by the way if you like my channel
do me a messy favor smash the like
button
drop a comment below i wouldn't be able
to do videos if you didn't ask questions
because my content is answering your
questions
he says i've just subscribed and liked
the video thank you so much florian
my question is if a house has four
bedrooms and two reception rooms can i
make one into another bedroom by just
adding a bed and selling it as a five
bed house
yeah you can like literally the number
of bedrooms in a house
can actually be subjective because if
you're running a
like a room with a sofa in it
and a tv is a sitting room a room
with a bed in it and a wardrobe is a
bedroom
so yeah you can do that as long as
there's windows and things in the
property
for sure any planning permissions for
this no you don't
if there's a bed in it it's a bedroom
you know
the only time a room is is like if it's
a loft conversion but the loft
conversion
hasn't had planning permission and it's
a bit then sometimes there's issues but
if it's just a room
and you put a bed in it and call it a
bedroom that's okay
um i was wondering because in an area i
found a 4x2 reception room selling about
25
but listen you're not going to add value
by doing this
you're not going to be able to put a bed
in this in the reception room and
suddenly add 50 000 value to the house
because you've also lost the reception
room
so you've just changed the names of
rooms so from a
rentability point of view if you're
doing if you're renting out as a
multi-let
you can rent it for more because you're
renting out room by room but you're not
gonna
add value to a property by just saying
that room isn't sitting within the
bedroom i i don't know if this helps but
anyway good luck keep me posted take it
on astante
james would you be still able to find
success and profit in
rent to rent method now during the
pandemic
absolutely have you seen the winners
wednesdays
every single week doing rent events as
long as you do them properly you need to
understand the market if you're trying
to rent a rent and you're trying to do
service accommodation for tourists
on a beach you're going to struggle
right now in fact you're not going to
struggle you're going to die
financially right now if you're doing it
if you're doing rent to hmos
i i and the area is popping people are
people are renting rooms like crazy
right now why because of because of the
pandemic
because they're downsizing because
they're struggling financially
so you're providing affordable
accommodation such as hmo which is
multiled room by room
but then you're renting a property off
of a landlord and paying him a direct
monthly small rent and then you're
turning into a hmo in a popular area
with popular demand you gotta check the
supine demand but yeah you absolutely
can
peter calling wanting to get the money
out of my property
i own outright 145 000 pounds
i want to use as much of this to invest
in property what would you do
peter calling i would get a mortgage
advisor and i would ask them
how much can you get out how much equity
can you get
out typically if you know if it's a if
it's a buy to that property
you better get about 75 loan to value if
you live in the property it might be
more
then take that property out they're
going to ask what you want to use the
money for and you're going to tell them
to reinvest in property
pull it out borrow against the property
that you own outright
and then use that money to then reinvest
and build your property empire that
that's what i
am doing and have done um so yeah
do it chloe and olivia so i've been
watching you for a while we have a four
bed property at the moment two of them
bought and paid deposits by remortgage
previous properties
i want to ask if i'm going to keep doing
this keep buying and then keep
re-mortgaging and getting capital to pay
deposits what's the risk for this is it
a safe way to move forward
so you've got to be adding value to the
property you can't buy a property
and then six months later just refinance
it if you've bought it with a mortgage
in the first place
because when you go to refinance it the
new mortgage company is going to go
you've already got a mortgage on this so
you need what you need to do is you need
to have added value to the property push
the value up
and if you push the value up then you
can get a new mortgage and you can pull
more money out and you can reinvest it
so the risk well the i mean
i guess you could say the risk is if
it's not cash flowing well you know if
you're
if you're using the strategy to build a
property portfolio and to build an
empire
but all your properties aren't cash
flowing and you've got bad tenants or
you've got no tenants
the mortgage payments are high because
you're leveraged
but you can't cover the mortgage
payments then that's a risk but if you
buy properties that are
bringing in good cash flow each month
then
i guess there's a risk with anything
there's a risk with not the risk of not
doing it is you have to
i tell you what i tell you what could
could go wrong you know if you don't do
this
you could end up having to work in a job
as a slave until you're 67. that's
that's
that's the ultimate risk so with
everything there's risk every time you
buy a property or
do anything there's risk there's risk
when you leave the house because you can
get hit by a car there's risk when you
don't leave the house that you could
like everything's risky to a point but
what you want to do is educate yourself
and look at the reward versus the risk
and say
look of course the chance that this this
could i could lose some money here or i
could waste some time here but what's
the reward
and then you want to do a risk analysis
and make the decision which is going to
help you towards your ultimate goal
and what i teach is financial freedom
most people's goal is to
please people and live a quiet life and
you know be a good boy or good girl and
get promoted you know get school good
school get grades
save up money their goal is to pay off
the mortgage you know
retire without you know being being too
poor
that's most people's goal my goal is
financial freedom my goal is to leave a
legacy my goal is to grow an empire
so i'm going to make all my decisions
towards that goal so you know you've got
to always make your own decisions based
on your goals
anyway i hope it helps all right next
kevin
says how do you include the interest of
a bridging loan on a brr strategy
how you include it is when you're going
to be okay so typically bridging
loans might be around about one percent
per month also there could be an
an entry and exit fee so if you're
borrowing a hundred thousand pound on a
bridging loan
and you're paying one percent a month
that's going to be a thousand pounds a
month
if you need it for six months you're
just gonna factor in six thousand pounds
cost to this deal and then is there is
there an exit fee and an entry fee so
you're going gonna have to ask the
bridging company what their fees are
then you have to calculate it and then
when you're working out the profits of
the deal you're gonna have to work out
whether you can afford to pay that or
not
so hope that helps sm thank you for q a
sunday you're so welcome sm
is there anything we can do to help the
lenders the lender surveyor
when visiting the property to maximize
the value following a refurb for a brr
yeah for sure firstly be there be polite
have all the receipts tell them what
you've done
if you've bought the property cheap
prior they'll be able to see that so
don't think they're stupid and don't
know that
just tell them why and how you got it so
cheap maybe the landlord was selling off
lots of properties and was motivated
show them the before and after pictures
leave them with a folder that they can
take back to the office because when
they get back to the office or the next
day
they've probably viewed six houses and
they've kind of forgotten yours so you
want to leave them with
the receipts and the before and after
pictures and if you've don't try and do
do a hard sell or tell them what to do
because they're not like that
but if if next door sold for 110 and you
think
okay that's good maybe just tell them oh
you know as you've probably seen next
door todd for 110 so
but anyway you do your job here's here's
some before and after pictures
here's some receipts you know and hope
for the best but
that's best that's the best you can do
ines
says hi samuel love all your videos and
content that you post regularly on a
daily basis that's right i do a video
every single day you better subscribe
um got the question if you don't mind of
course not this is why we're here
me and my twin brother bought our first
residential house two years ago
in that two years time we saved up sixty
thousand pounds to invest again
good for you if you are in our shoes
what would you rather do take
one name off the current mortgage and
just buy a second residential home
do it up pull some money out and rent it
out or start our own company
and focus on buy to let's um probably my
inkling will just be decided to set up a
company and just focus on
and just focus on building your property
portfolio through a company
um your twin brother that's cool i mean
what you're talking about here is should
you maybe take one off the mortgage and
then buy one as a residential do it up
and then sell it or or refinance it
i mean there are there are tax
advantages if you're going to be living
in a property
and you can get better rates but it
depends on if you want to do that do you
want to live in the property or is this
strictly a business
um but in terms of the most tax
efficient way to do it and everything
like that i just look at again what
is your goal what do you want to achieve
talk to an accountant and see what the
most tax efficient is
it sounds to me that you're going to win
because you've got properties already
you've been following my advice
you've now got another 60 grand you're
going to win win win win win put some of
that money even if it's
10 into education i would highly
recommend that as well
because that's going to make you go a
lot further rohit
mera says what do you think about
liverpool for investment and do you have
any good deal sourcing company you can
recommend thank you and merry christmas
it's kind of after christmas but i
appreciate it anyway
um yeah i think liverpool's great um
again if you know what you're doing
there's parts of liverpool that are
terrible there's parts that are
brilliant but overall as a whole
liverpool has bottomed out and i think
it's going to bounce up
and the returns are really good
generally liverpool deal sourcing
companies
i mean i have a deal sourcing company
which i am a silent partner in
i don't get too involved it's called
better source limited but they're a
fabulous company
alice they're cunningham heads it up and
there's a great team there so check out
bettersourced
ltd.co dot credit uk but i would say to
be honest i wouldn't start paying deal
sources because
i would just do it yourself you only
want to pay deal sources when you're
paying for their time not for their
expertise
you want to know what you're doing
yourself and even i say that even with
someone that has a deal sourcing company
you know i mean i i have 50 shares in
the company but i say no
get the knowledge yourself understand
how to do yourself get your hands dirty
and then once you've started buying a
couple houses and you understand the
process
then maybe start paying deal sources
because you get it it puts you in a much
more powerful position
benji fox what do you think will happen
if you teach too many people to get into
this industry and make money from deal
sourcing rent-to-rent vrr
what would be your advice to be to
differ the crowd for different from the
crowds
who are doing what you teach uh benji
i everything i teach i do so it's
difficult for me to say how am i gonna
differ from the crowd who i'm teaching
because if i was teaching
something but then i was differing from
the crowd myself what that would mean
would that
mean i'm teaching something that's not
as good which would actually be
a massive hindrance to my students and i
don't think i would have the success
students that i have
every single week coming on the show
winning
no one helps as many people as i do to
become financially free in property in
the whole of the uk
you know i mean a lot of people copy me
they're copying my videos they copy my
style they do
but no one copies winners on a wednesday
why because they're just not getting the
success students that i'm getting and
the reason i do that is because i
teach what actually works i don't teach
you know you come to my crash course
which by the way is free i don't sit
there with a presentation
slideshow of something that i did seven
night years ago you know
i actually find live deals today i show
people what i'm doing i get them to do
it that's why they succeed
and in terms of am i worried about
everyone succeeding in property and then
there's no deals on the left of the
left on the table no because that's
that's poverty mindset that's thinking
from a position of lack like there's
only so many deals
no i can teach exactly what i'm doing
and you're going to do it in
burnley but i'm not doing it in burnley
you're going to apply in scotland or
italy or australia like there's so many
deals there's so much money to be made
you'll become successful and then we'll
end up collabing you've got to think
collaboratively rather than
competitively so
that that's the way i see it hope that
helps
always dunabal says i'm looking to get
started deal sourcing and i've already
begun speaking to a few investors about
what they want and how i can help my
first few investors are already booked
but i was wanting to know my first few
viewings already but i wanted to know
how to best
evaluate a renovation cost as i haven't
had much experience
refurbishing yet that's going to come
with time ask the estate agent if it's
on with an agent
what they think the refurb cost will be
they won't really know but they'll give
you maybe a bit of an idea
um i mean we do have training which goes
through this
i wouldn't be bringing builders to every
property maybe be upfront sell the deal
and say look
i reckon the refurb's gonna be about 15
grand but i might be wrong
so you know do your own due diligence mr
investor and if there's any issues
let me know and i'll give you a full
refu refund if there's any issues you
know go and view the property yourself
um just be really honest with your
investors and say look i'm really good
at finding deals i can crunch the
numbers
i can get in there i'm really good at
negotiating with estate agents but my
strong point is not the refurb so i
think it's about 15 grand and then let
the
investor go out and have a look at it
bring a builder or whatever um
honesty always wins and then we have to
start somewhere
caramel puppy what type of properties
are suitable for a joint venture a joint
venture just means someone else is going
to be taking some of the pie which just
means you want as much profit as you can
so so if you've got a very profitable
deal you can bring in jv partners if
there's not much profit in there anyway
you're going to struggle but you
shouldn't be touching those houses
anyway
chloe cunningham if i was to do a lease
option agreement on a property and
turned into a hmong rented it out in
an an up-and-coming article four area
would i have the grandfather rights to
the property as a hmo once i have come
to the end of the lease option or would
it go back
as a single let yes you'd have the
grandfather rights because you'd be able
to prove to the council that you were
renting this property out as a multi-let
with the ast contracts
and that property would have automatic
green light planning permission yes
charlie t i say i'm aware that i can't
transfer properties from my personal
name into my new limited company without
basically selling them to myself and
that is not financially viable but
can i refinance my first and only rental
property one which was purchased in my
own name
after successful gains and then use the
released equity to then put down
a deposit on another rental property but
this time through my new limited company
in form of the director's loan
yes you can now listen i'm not a tax
expert
but that uh i mind something yes you can
because i've done that
many many many times in fact my
properties majority of my portfolio
because it was built up in my own
personal name and then when they brought
in the tax
changes section 24 i'm like maybe i need
to switch it to a
limited company but it wasn't viable as
you say without selling them to yourself
it's just not worth doing it doesn't
make financial sense but if you
refinance
um you should be able to do that no
problem but speak to an accountant good
job my friend
dan goodwin my question for you is
after using a software like deal sourcer
app i found several properties that i
think would work well as a lease option
agreement
however how do i get in contact with the
owners and not have
to try and get an agent to pass on the
lease option agreement offer
um view tell the agent that you can only
view in the evening
and then they'll say oh i can't do that
and you'll get oh man i'm ready for in
the evening and then they'll go
ah let me check to see if the owner's
afraid boom sheker you did that
all right next matt you make it sound
awesome thanks
you know what people say to me people
people get upset with me about that
samuel makes it too easy
yeah in the same way that david beckham
makes football look easy i make property
look easy i take it as a compliment
my issue is how to find the right
property in the first place i live in
birmingham and the only properties i can
find for a hundred thousand pounds are a
terrible
properties and there is zero way of
doing them up and making it worth two
hundred thousand pounds
zilch so how do we do that in the first
place matt i did i did one in birmingham
as a joint venture massage recently
it was bought for 150 we spent 120 on it
and now it sold for just shy of 400. so
they are there
you just need to know rather than
scrolling right move and just looking
you need to know how to get in with
agents
how to get in their little black book
what to say this is a people business
you need to get trained man you can't
say there's no deals in birmingham when
i'm doing deals in birmingham
you just can't you just need to say how
do i find them
i would say you build relationships with
agents because a good relationship is
better than a good deal
you get a good relationship they bring
you the deals believe me
oliver saunders smith i wasn't able to
catch most of the last crash
course only being able to see it from 7
pm onwards
i really enjoyed it and i'm guessing i
missed most of it i was quite skeptical
at first mainly due to warnings from my
family and friends but from what i saw
the crash course was actually really
eye-opening
and i can't wait to see the next one in
full or recording of the last one if it
exists
that's awesome i'm sorry you missed most
of it and no we don't record the crash
courses it's live it's live it's real
i'm only 19 and currently live with my
parents and possibly will for the next
year
what can i do to play the game smart and
maximize my investment money whilst also
being employed full-time
it will take me a few years before i can
start earning a moderate income but i
would rather start sooner than later is
it worth waiting or getting stuck in as
soon as possible
what do you think listen what do you
think i'm gonna say do you think i'm
gonna say yeah wait
yeah i think it's worth you waiting just
do nothing just focus on your job
and wait wait for what you're going to
die
one day and when you die you have a
little tombstone
that's always going to be left and on
the tombstone there's going to be two
dates and there's going to be a dash
and right now the dash
is what you're in i wouldn't wait for
anything i'd grab
life and i'd grab opportunities by the
horns
and i would jump in and sink or swim
i'd go back to the crash course again
but don't jump on at 7 pm
and do everything that you need to do to
win
because i'll tell you something right
now everyone's waiting
waiting for the pandemic to blow over
waiting for this
waiting for that waiting to see what the
implications of brexit are waiting to
see
and they'll still be waiting when
they're 67. people say
why were you waiting around because 2021
interest rates were an all-time low
and there was so much opportunities and
hmos article 4 was coming in and there
was grandfather right so there was
landlords were giving over rent to rent
because they were scared about the
tenant eviction bans and there was deals
all over the place but you
waited and did nothing don't do that
that's my opinion but you need to do
what's right for you your goal
your life your outcome all i can do is
share what i do
and give some encouragement to you guys
and listen this is this is this is not
like i'm not telling you to do something
that's never been done before this is
something that every single day
people are winning in this business and
there's very few people
that will share openly like i do and
teach how to do it
so anyone that's watching this video if
you're watching this video right now and
you really want to do this
i'd like to invite you to join me at the
free
property investors crash course i'll
leave a link in the description
i'll see you there let's make 2021 the
best
year ever thank you so much for watching
i look forward to seeing you
next time
you